this is a pretty famous vol okay what
you've got is you could call it a double
quarter pipe much like the double
quarter-pounder which is actually a half
cut its a double for cutter and everyone
what you've got is here you've got a
quarter of a cylindrical pipe an
identical quarter of a surgical plan and
they're coming together and they're
meeting at right angles okay and a
particular volume we're interested i
haven't drawn yet so that we can draw it
together and you will see by the way
i've talked a lot about this the colors
in your diagram or the clothes you have
access to the hugely valuable like they
really really help okay so i'm going to
do my best you can see they're going to
meet together at this kind of funny join
because i'm not going to draw them in
because it would crowd my diagram too
much but each one of these here is kind
of a quadrant of a quarter of a
circumference right so you got this arc
come all the way along same aren't
coming all the way long and they're
going to meet together add another arc
that has the same kind of shape okay so
you've got that guy there it's kind of
I've sort of exaggerated how much it
bends over just so you can see the
curvature of it now what about the rest
of it well the place where they're going
to drive together if you can think about
this quadrant here and if we went all
the way to the end of the pipe until
this this corner here or rather that
face you're going to have this profile
this cross section is going to appear on
the back right over here so it's going
to have this kind of shape like so so
think of that as the continuation of
this face that's curved on the edge here
right in exactly the same way when I
look from this side you're going to get
this cross section is going to continue
continue continue and eventually then on
the back of that flat face this you're
getting that check okay so now we're
almost there we always have the volume
that we want if I connect there we go
these here this is actually annoying
this is it right this part where the two
quarter pipes intersect where they
overlap as it were it is we'd awkwards
kind of shape in the middle ok this is
the volume that I
and that's kind of in fact all that you
get as a set up right now we need to add
a bit of extra information on here to
try and work out what's going on the
only constant they've given us is that
the radius of this of the quarter pipes
is a ok then I'll I didn't call it off
but anyway from here to to sort of see
this a little clearer what we want is
another diagram so wrong color what I'm
going to do is I want to take just that
part of it just the actual volume itself
pull it out over here and then I can
start to think about what cross sections
are going to be useful to me ok so let's
replicate this diagram just this volume
part here and I'm going to help you by
saying start from this vertical axis
like so here cuz I'm gonna need three
diagrams in fact start from there do all
the straight plants first so you can see
I've got this base here which is going
to be critically important to us so it
sort of going off at this angle this
angle favor ok so these are all the
straight bits and all its left is to
connect the dots this guy ok do you see
the shape ok now once you have this in
place you say ok I want a part of this I
want to work out what things do i need
to add together in order to get this one
ok now when you think about getting
cross-sections often the question will
help you out and tell you what cross
section that you take but before I show
you what the questions are you where do
you think you would go where could you
or what access could you slice so you'll
get the not the same cross-section every
time good because that were your prison
but and a similar cross section every
time any suggestions we go so I could go
flat so view this kind of like as a
stack of vertical slices so I'm going to
go to that suggestion one of the reasons
you can know that is if you try out and
keep your perspective you if I draw for
example a parallel line yeah yeah so I'm
parallel to these edges on the bottom
yeah okay you'll see oh yeah I had this
same quadrilateral whereas if you try
and do it any other way you're getting
these weed curves that you have to
negotiate so what's happening is this
shape is getting and you I could do one
more up here these shapes are getting
progressively smaller as you go up but
importantly they are all similar to each
other okay so this is the actual slice
I'm going to take here's my shape so in
order to think about this right you can
see I've got a whole bunch of these
maybe I'll show this one too so you can
see what is varying what is the
thickness of this thing as I I move up
and get different slices okay well you
can see it's not this x-axis which I I
guess would say is horizontal or this
why artists going off in this direction
it's another access all together I guess
you could call it Z if you but being
that I've oriented it vertically it's
kind of like part of the height of this
shape so the question itself actually
takes that and says okay I'm going to
say this distance you I'm going to call
that H and I'm going to let H be my
variable okay so if that distance there
is H then i can define the thickness of
this cross section as Delta X that's
what's changing ok so I've already made
a huge amount of progress to
understanding this question but there's
one last piece left to work out um the
volume of course you got to work out
what each of these slices is equal to
now this is actually going to be
remembering that you started from like
quadrants and all these kinds of things
that are equally because this is a this
is also a you rid of that which means
that this is also a but because these
are the same kind of quarter pipe coming
together this is also a right so what
kind of shape do we have there on the
base it's a square ok so that's really
nice to me because all i need is the
site
length of this square and then I'll be
able to work out the area for them okay
so I need a few extra labels here to
help me because I need to draw one last
diagram and they always work out what is
the side length of this square like how
do I sifted out from here okay so what
I'm going to do is specially excuse me
I'm going to call that point there well
it's where all the axes meet so a
natural name for it would be 0 for the
origin and then I'm just going to name
this square let's just call it a v-sit
it okay that's a pretty scene name a b c